yeah sorry welcome to this video playing
Osama from Germany officer okay yeah
let's stay within the default territory
maybe a Kingson you know a modern modern
defense yeah this is some quite good for
white but you know I don't know that
don't think that this is particularly
great for black you have fun some
problems here with the control over them
he for scrap yeah F three years ago came
or H three years both are quite good
I'm not sure about g5 he can play Knight
h5 probably this is also good
look g19 throat she was also not bad I
wasn't 100% sure about age five like age
three age five
maybe this is suicidal for black age
five but at least I'm preventing even
that now it's not so clear where's King
yeah okay he's going he's going short
you know this is some intending b5
sucking sucking up on that's probably
never going to be enough compensation
but you need to somehow still up some
trouble
hmm
okay I'm playing this in a very solid
fashion now it takes on c4 I don't mind
that
and before I've got 94 and maybe this
wasn't the absolute best way to play
I was expecting eform
you have that upon you maybe just
protected
now that it is some counterplay
a43 quite quite a problem
yeah it's not looking good and he's
playing everything instantly
yeah I need to get get some quick
concrete play on the kingside otherwise
I just get rolled over on the queenside
probably get rolled over anyway
is a bit slower you're just winning a
problem but he's not meeting me was
awesome so this is probably not not the
most dangerous yep
I'm threatening on aged six at the end
yeah night as all that so I've lightly
form to UM to strengthen the attack
right now this is a very unlucky piece
okay I can I can just take here now this
is at least a draw by perpetual and I
should do that with this time situation
okay don't get too vicious
no way to play this for window
check
check yeah I'm thinking about this 90
foster but there's no direct win so
that's let's draw this mmm
yeah then it is just a drone I was
actually getting rather optimistic here
because of this awkward position only
four but it's it's probably just just a
drawn yeah I think he was in this
position it was much better and instead
of one second to this move yeah it's
it's a matter I don't know I always very
often get criticized here for my
criticism about time management but one
second you have two extra minutes and
obviously great position just invest ten
seconds and try to win win the game on
position this is not good really it's
too slow you can compute their gifts e6
but also just pile up on the B file this
is just very slow for one phone and this
is already a draw it's enough enough how
to play and I wonder really if there's
more with 94 but it doesn't it doesn't
materialize I just need to take this
draw him yeah okay but can you do I was
in trouble before and he allowed that
yeah thanks for watching